-Let's talk about North Korea,
because you have
this military background.
When you hear the president
use terms like "fire and fury,"
I feel as though
that's what he thinks
someone with a strong
military will would say.
But as someone
who was in the military,
is that the kind of language
that military people use?
-No. The toughest
fighters out there,
the operators out there,
are the quietest,
most understated people
you will ever meet,
and, frankly,
he's not helping us
by engaging in this battle
of -- of terminology.
I mean, you can't out-hyperbole
a dictator who's crazy --
a man who executed his own uncle
with an aircraft --
an antiaircraft machine gun.
-Yeah.
-So Trump is not gonna
out-crazy Kim Jong-un.
Stop it.
You're the Commander-in-Chief
of the greatest military
on the face of the Earth.
Act like it.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you think...
Obviously, he feels that
presenting toughness
is the same as toughness.
Is that --
Do you think it's a mistake
to present toughness
the way he is?
Or is that --
Or is there an argument
that that's the smart thing
to do.
When you do have
the best military in the world,
do you let people know?
-Well, you have to understand
that Kim Jong-un
is trying to consolidate power.
And one of the ways
he's doing that
is by executing anybody
that doesn't please him.
The other is to tell
the North Korean people,
"You're starving,
but it's because
the world wants to attack us,
so I have
to take the money that,
instead of giving you rice,
I'm gonna use it
to build a nuclear weapon.
And when you've got
the leader of the free world,
the president
of the United States,
engaging in this,
all you're doing is --
You're just writing
the propaganda for Kim Jong-un.
All of those tweets
that Trump has been putting out,
or these statements,
Kim Jong-un is gonna put out
through his own
propaganda machine.
He might as well
be working for him.
That doesn't help us.
-I think, though,
now Trump thinks --
[ Applause ]
He probably sees these like,
"Now my tweets
are even in North Korea.
This is huge for me."
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, well, again,
you remember,
you're never gonna beat a guy
who fires people
by killing them
with antiaircraft weapons.
-Yeah, well, now,
I also want to ask about this.
You know,
you obviously believe --
You have a background that leads
to a diverse
part of the military.
It seems to me
that diversity in the military
is an important thing.
Donald Trump said
he was doing a favor
to the military
by his trans ban --
through his trans ban.
What do you think of that?
What do you think
the president said
to the people in the military
with that choice?
-He basically said that, one,
"Even if you
have served honorably,
we don't want you anymore."
And that means that
if you are trans,
then you're
gonna have two choices --
either quit and take
your experience with you
or hide who you are
and make yourself susceptible
to blackmail.
'Cause that's what happened
under "Don't ask, don't tell."
Under "Don't ask, don't tell,"
a lot of folks
were actually
being held hostage by people
who knew that they were gay
and threatened them
and threatened their careers.
So, that's not helpful.
And on the other hand,
we have had
tens of thousands
of trans servicemen and women
who have served honorably,
who've bled,
who've died for this country.
And to turn away people who are
willing to sacrifice for us
is foolish at best.
-I agree with that.
[ Applause ]
You obviously --
You served your country,
you sacrificed for your country
via the military.
But you always make it clear,
it strikes me,
that there are other ways
to serve for young people.
You don't necessarily
have to do it via the military.
Give us some other ideas
of how you think
people can serve this country?
-Well,
I've introduced legislation,
along with Seth Moulton
and the great John Lewis
that would allow people
to earn, for example,
college money for service.
You should be able to pick up
chalk, a hammer,
a ladle at a soup kitchen
and earn college money
just as much
as I picked up a rifle
and earned college money.
We all have a chance to serve.
Even if just once a year
you go out volunteer,
you're doing something.
Less than one-half of 1% of this
nation wears the uniform,
and that's an awful big load
for a small percentage to carry.
So let's all do
a little carrying.
Doesn't mean you have
to go join the military.
Doesn't mean you got
to go get blown up.
God forbid.
I tried not to get blown up.
But --
Didn't work too well, but...
But do something.
Do something.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How much longer
a break do you have?
When do you have
to go back to D.C.?
-I'm going back tonight.
-You're going back
to D.C. tonight?
I thought you guys
had a recess now. No?
-Well, people call it a recess,
but it's actually
a district work period.
I'm traveling the state.
I was out in --
on a river barge
on the Mississippi 48 hours ago,
and now I'm here, and I'm
going back home tomorrow.
-"Recess" sounds so much better
than "district work period."
[ Laughter ]
-I thought
I was getting a recess,
but then they told me,
"Here's your schedule."
I'm like, "Wait.
That's not right."
-"That's not recess!
I thought
we were playing dodgeball."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.
Continued luck in Washington.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Senator Tammy Duckworth,
everybody!